well joining me now is environmental
campaigner Danica McCarthy Joshua Boyle
spokesperson uh Chloe naldrett and the
former England uh test Cricket Legend
Sir Jeffrey boykill so welcome to all of
you well let me start with Chloe Chloe
neldre uh Chloe
even the people who were funding you
even the millionaires behind a lot of
this stuff they're sick of it the sick
of the performative stuff the attention
seeking the wrecking of stuff that other
people enjoy they recognize none of it
is turning anyone's opinion uh they're
as sick of it as I am why do you all
keep doing this
well thanks for having me on today
Pierce um what you've just done
beautiful summary of the actions that
we've been doing over the last year of
course has looked a lot at how we
protest but you haven't mentioned a word
about why
why is it that a bunch of really
ordinary
community-minded uh law-abiding people
are taking this kind of action and the
answer is because we're in a climate
emergency and our government is not
taking it seriously this action at Lords
today isn't the biggest climate story of
the day the biggest climate story of the
day is the fact that the government's
own climate change committee which is
headed by the conservative peer Lord
Devon has found that the government's
Net Zero strategy is failing on every
single one of its targets that means
they're not keeping us safe now and they
are
you know what come on shows like this
and debate that I'll invite you on to
the proper debate about it my message to
you come on any time
the only way we get listening it's not
the only way you get on that's a
complete myth there have been regular
debates on shows like mine that don't
involve a reaction to the kind of
ridiculous nonsense we saw today the
truth is you've become a group of
Records you just like wrecking things
for the sake of wrecking nobody is
coming along to your cause because of
these stupid stunts we all think you're
a bunch of pure old spoiled brats who
are just going out of their way to cause
other people inconvenience and ruin
their fun that is the reality you might
well have serious problems you might
well hang on you might well have a
serious point to make or many serious
points to make I might well agree with
some of those points I probably do but
you know what the more of these things
you do are things that I enjoy and my
friends enjoy and my family enjoys and
other people with their friends and
families enjoy the more families that
you stop and getting to work or getting
their kids to school for important exams
or getting to funerals or whatever it
may be the more you do that the more we
hate you and the more we don't want to
have anything to do with you or give you
a platform to talk about the stuff that
actually is more important as you
rightly say why don't you just stop the
stupid stunts stop wrecking because
people's lives this won't stay in the
news and it won't stay in the
conversation and perhaps what we're
doing by interrupting the things that
you need to do that are important to you
that you love is we're making you think
about everything you're making me think
you're a bunch of morons said today
you're not making me think about your
clothes nobody at laws today we're
thinking about it this is about climate
change we saw the orange powder the
whole crowd started booing unfortunately
England's looking good but Johnny talk
uh actually no I'm going to cut you off
I'm going to get it I want to go to Sir
Jeffrey boycott Jeffrey
um you're a cricket Legend and I
remember back in the 70s a pitch being
dug up aheadingly uh which wrecked a
test match in a different kind of
protest but this this series of attacks
on stuff that most britons just like
watching the snooker the cricket the
Chelsea flower show what do you make of
it does it convince you that you should
take this kind of thing seriously
no I watched it today and I just started
laughing I thought the England players
did well and with the Aussie batsman
they made a barrier at one end for one
of them so they couldn't get through and
then the uh the staff came on and
grabbed him on Rugby tackled him Johnny
picked up the other one and the orange
powder he actually went on the ground
about eight and nine ten yards away from
the pitch yeah so he didn't do any
damage whatsoever and I just laughed I
thought it was foolish I I just thought
it was stupid there's a serious point to
this uh Jeffrey which is Hadley actually
got to the wicked itself you know these
wickets in a test match at Lords on day
one of a five-day match they're pretty
sacred pieces of land right if they got
there and begun to do actual damage to
the Wicket sprayed their paint
everywhere actually it could have
wrecked the entire test match
yes and everybody's got tickets for
tomorrow Saturday whatever whatever day
all the refunding that that up some few
days at the cricket will be spoiled
that's what happened with the George
Davies that's what it was in 75 it was
uh some people got in through the night
they didn't have security guards then or
or dogs you know through the night to
stop that and they dug up the pitch and
they painted it and it was all about
freeing George Davies who was in jail at
the time they supposedly thought he was
wrongly put in jail and when Tony Greg
and Ian Shuffle the two captains were
walking up come to the ground early
because there's been a problem
Greggy was smart enough to Satan Chapel
can we touch a fresh peach for you and
we'd play on that chapels of whoa we're
not stupid because as you know and any
Cricket lover knows these pictures that
they actually bat on have been prepared
and rolled and made Flat and pancake so
that you get a fair highly true bounds
if you play on a freshly known pitch the
ball Zips all over the course in
Australia with a loss so the whole thing
was abandoned yeah that's right it was
and the whole the whole Integrity of a
of an international cricket match say
the ashes like this is reliant on the
pitch and the Integrity of that pitch
that's why it may look like a Purell
stunt actually if they got to where they
were trying to get to and who knows what
they had planned for when they got on
the Wicket they could have raped the
Lord's test match and I come back again
Jeffrey to this sense that I have that
the British public are not getting moved
one iota to support this cause the more
that they do this kind of thing to stuff
that we all enjoy
well if they got to the pitch and ruined
it in some way then there might have
been hell on they might not have got out
of the ground in one piece that's not to
say that's right but people would have
been angry that the game was ruined and
ruined for the next few days I mean this
is an ashes there isn't anything bigger
than cricket and there isn't the ground
better in the world than Lords and Mecca
of tricky yeah so it wouldn't have gone
down well and I felt at the time that's
why I laughed I thought this is silly
this is negative this is not going to do
you any good because the people are
across they're going to be mud as hell
if you ruin it
I completely agree
um let me come to you then uh I've
always felt you're a more reasonable
talker about this kind of thing I know
you've had a long time commitment to it
I want to read you again what Trevor
Nielsen said to the Sunday Times at the
weekend it was really interesting he
said I absolutely absolutely believe
this kind of thing's become now
counterproductive I just feel like it
has to be said by somebody that was
involved in the beginning of what it's
become this is going to require an
immensely difficult navigation of the
middle and the activists are ostracizing
the exact people they need to engage
they're creating an excuse for people to
stay on the sidelines blocking Bridges
is a lot easier than Building Bridges
and that is what we need to do we're
going to succeed now I read that and I I
thought good on you good on you for not
being intransigent good on you for
recognizing what I've been saying
repeatedly and others which is it's not
the cause itself that is causing all the
friction on the problem it is the
methodology of forcing people to come
along the road with this cause and if
you change the methodology you might
well bring more people with you do you
accept that no I don't because what he's
actually saying is he's contradicting
what has happened in protest movements
over the centuries what has happened
tell me one movement that's involves
systematic wrecking of things that
British people enjoy doing I think I
think the if you take a step back and
you look at the protests that desktop
all of them they've been minor things
because they're not minor though they
are 10 10 minutes with a bit of dust is
is minor however the the really
interesting thing about today's protest
is what it brought attention to in the
media the media this afternoon is
talking about who is sponsoring the
cricket match today it's JP Morgan J.P
Morgan is the world's largest funder of
fossil fuel destruction I've not heard
anybody talking about JP Morgan it's in
the BBC it's not the guy honestly I was
at Lord's I was at Lords until six
o'clock nobody was talking about JP
Morgan or any involvement they may have
in football media today honestly I've
not seen the word read the reports in
the BBC
what they're talking about is JP Morgan
is the world's largest bank 454 billion
pounds invest in fossil fuels since
Paris and they're sponsoring today so I
think it's a really important reminder
it reminds me of the rugby projects
that's the same again and people like
you reacted to the rugby no I mean I
mean you don't know anything about what
I thought about those questions you were
responding to this protest
I would have people like you want to
debate the serious issues absolutely we
do that every night on the show we have
a lot of we had a big serious debate
last night about racism in Britain for
example the people involved in that
debate haven't spent the last few months
running around wrecking everything
they're not a wrecking machine they want
to have a debate which actually leads to
proper change that's what I would like
to see with your calls for just oddly
just stop oil everyone now Associates
just stop oil with just a bunch of
morons wrecking people's lives that's
what people like you call them I I would
actually call them Heroes because this
was heroicing
everything was said about the rugby
protest and the apartheid area let's
let's remember what's happening with the
Cricket World you talk about the
sacredness of the sport and the sequence
of the cricket pitch look at the cricket
in the world Caribbean destroyed by
hurricanes Pakistan destroyed by floods
in the extreme heat what those
cricketers are doing today is taking
their sight on the wrong side
you're saying cricketers should have
should have said stood up and Stood
Beside the stuff
no funding for new fossil fuels now this
is where you lose me this is there's a
serious debate to be had about what's
been going on in those countries I get
it I believe climate change is real I
believe it's dangerous I believe in the
core inherent
essence of your protest right I just
hate the methodology and so I can tell
you do 99 of this country and they can't
stand it I can say back to you I've been
involved in this for 30 years I spent 10
years local campaigning tenures in
politics Deputy available Democrats I've
done Camp campaigning I've done
petitions I've done marching I know
you're reduced to chucking painting
around no I haven't tucked paint around
but you're supporting them I'm acting
support because nothing else is worse so
please tell me we've tried politics
actually you say nothing else is worse
the UK has one of the best records in
the world in measures to combat climate
change now that is an irrefutable fact
and If you deny that you are actually
denying the very thing that you accuse
other people to do which is reality
there are two things Britain is better
than the world in in in most countries
in reducing the carbon emissions of our
electricity system everything else we're
disastrous and the most important thing
about Britain which links to today's
protest and JP Morgan Bank is we're one
of the largest funders of new
why don't you go to China
and India and Russia and pull these
stunts there why is it only the safe
places like the UK the just stop oil
chucked the stuff around at Major
sporting events and things that people
love let me tell you why because there's
a moral cowardice at the heart of what
you do it's a bit like Greta Thunder it
doesn't take Greta thundberg you never
see her in Beijing ranting away about
the Chinese government even though the
worst polluters in the world are the
Chinese so the people causing the real
damage on pollution none of your
protesters have the gumption or the
moral guts to go and wreck the lives of
those people in those countries because
you know what would happen and you pick
on the easy places who are doing the
most to try and combat it and in the
process yes you piss off the entire
country and I don't get this I mean do
you accept the point that Britain is
responsible for 15 of new funding and
philosophers globally and secondly we're
up response for over 50 percent
true or not here's what I accept Duke
said that's true here's what accept I'm
not going to quibble individual stats
because I haven't got the really
important stuff hang on I haven't got
that information in front of me what I
would say is as a broad brush stroke it
is undeniable that the UK is doing more
than most countries in the world who are
acute of the prosperous countries is
doing more to combat climate change than
most others that is a fact what I'm
agreeing with you is that we're doing
more on our electricity our own one
percent but the city of London and our
all corporations are funding that's my
advice of global admission here's my
advice so we have to protest my advice
no you don't it's the center of the
donuts come on shows like this and make
your argument don't go and rape people
with Morgan and Barclays and shell let
me go to the final word to to Jeffrey
boycott if you're still there Jeffrey
um I want to like the low Jeffrey I just
ask you are we going to win the ashes
no
I don't think so I think we should have
won we should have won an edge Boston we
win the game for 90 of the time yet we
lost it that's silly that is silly and
that's that's enough to cry you know
when you're winning the game 90 of the
time and you lose Australia is a good
team all right here's what I'm going to
do Jeffrey will you accept will you
accept a 100 pound bet because I say
England will win the ashes
I only bet when I'm batty
so Jeffrey it's a great honor a pleasure
to have you on the uh show I think it's
your first appearance on Piers Morgan
said please come back again I miss you
on the airwaves still a legend still as
sharp as well great to see you and thank
you to my two uh just top oil uh
contributors